hey guys oh no my lens is clouded hmm
could be from the fire extinguisher look
at you you're so dusty I'm off to the
airport it's probably like 5am got a bit
like four and now it's time to go Joey's
downstairs we had a sleepover last night
because were both heading to New York
excited I'm tired well let's roll not
before packing you
we made the security we're now getting
some coffee and some oatmeal really good
like spinach waste a crap I wish they
had like fresh-squeezed juice
yeah it's a starbucks in LA as a wine
bar did you know I had no idea I'd
neither haven't been so we should go
there yeah so we made some new york
jelly multiply it was really rude um
beat thumping 40 but I passed the hell
out I tried to edit it didn't work out I
was like am i hard to ever like bouncing
around Joey sent me a message from it
was I realized oh no that makes sense I
think it means I feel like figure out
ways context clues run away to the
talent and then have like a tea party
tonight after good rehearsals for break
out tomorrow and I need a nap yeah you
too my battery's gonna die oh my gosh I
made it to the hotel and immediately I
had to order room service closed
starving's I didn't anything on the
plane and we're here in the room this
arrived in seriously 10 minutes how do
they make this salmon so quick I don't
understand there's gonna be a really fun
week with like a bunch of youtubers so
I'm excited to bring you guys along for
the ride I'm sure you will see every
single angle from all the other
youtubers that are here too so yeah I'm
a neat barely made it to each other on
their string prominence yeah remember
that I remember I do not no way
what was I feel like that was active in
Canada
vlogging this is exciting so there's I
get you to create or something going on
here and the internet is like yr will be
tutors in New York right now we're
actually not sure we are here we're
gonna have fun we will also forgot my
battery charge on this camera over
square very easy oh it has slicks wheels
or okay oh so quick where are we right
now what's over here we are see above
our head this is creaky some new ones oh
this is the new version look at that
that's busy oh that's the strong
ones are small ones are regular boys on
these are we does it all and ordered
like yeah that's out of food okay oh hi
how's it go oh boy we're just thinking
about us here this is really really cute
get games holy moly this is the hot tub
that you can see from oh god I have a
weak grip here is how he didn't I drop
my phone today like 50 whoa that does
actually look really does it warm
cool okay I'm gonna need my blog now
because I don't have to edit any more
fish food and I'm shop already oh let's
go together come on